sie wollten in der bären schütz klamm
bei mixed in der steiermark ein wenig
wandern und die natur genießen
nun sind zwei wanderer tot acht leicht
oder schwer verletzt sie wurden opfer
eines schweren steinschlags bei den
toten soll es sich um eine frau aus
ungarn und um eine österreicherin
handeln
zwei frauen sterben durch einen
felssturz bei einer wanderung im
österreichischen klarmacht wanderer
werden verletzt einer davon schwer
mehrere fans stücke brechen aus den
steinwänden an der beliebten
wanderrouten bären schützt lahm und
stürzten in die tiefe
die geschosse zielen auf einen
darunterliegenden holzsteg genau zu
dieser zeit befinden sich dort die
wanderer
es kommt zum unglück die felsstücke
treffen mit starker wucht auf den
holzweg er wird teilweise zerstört die
wanderer werden überrascht und getroffen
sie haben keine chance
einige von ihnen werden sogar mit in die
tiefe gerissen eine 21-jährige
österreicherin und eine 50 jährige frau
ist um ganz sterben bei diesem felssturz
zur rettung kommen hubschrauber zum
einsatz
teilweise müssen personen nach dem
unglück aus einem bach geborgen werden
die rettungen der stoff ist gefährlich
die unglücksstelle ist eng laut der
bergrettung kommt es immer wieder zu
herausbrechen den fels stücken aber so
schlimm sei es noch nie gewesen
die ursache warum diese filz bereich
themes los gestürzte ski munition
erhebungen ist laufen die werden fordert
die mahlzeit moment durchgeführt haben
wir während das gelände begeben und mit
dem geologen und werden das ganze doch
natürlich auch kommentieren
durch gewitter und schneeschmelze sollen
sich immer wieder steine lösen erst am
sonntag wird ein wanderer von einem
herabstürzenden steinen getroffen
jährlich kommen rund 40.000 besucher für
die spektakuläre mehrstündige wanderung
in die klamm und aus österreich ist uns
jetzt unser bild reporter jörg
völkerling zugeschaltet jörg wie konnte
es zu so einer tragödie kommen aber das
weißt du heute am morgen das große
rätsel besteht nach wie vor die
alpinpolizei will heute mit einem
geologen auch dieses gelände sich
anschauen die wehren schütz klamm ist
gesperrt nichtsdestotrotz kommt immer
noch andere hierher die sich an den 700
meter hohen aufstieg zu einer alm machen
wollen
es ist österreichweit eine ziemlich
einmalige situation offenbar das sind so
einer schlucht so etwas passiert es gab
schon in anderen landesteilen also
fälle mit can you can you mit
kanufahrten da ging es aber eher um
menschliches versagen
eine mögliche erklärung ist ein schweres
gewitter was in der nacht auf dienstag
hier über der region niedergegangen ist
dabei könnte sich ein felsbrocken gelöst
haben und dann in die tiefe gestürzt
sein man geht inzwischen davon aus dass
es eine regelrechte gerölllawine war
augenzeugen berichten von bis zum
brotlaib großen gesteinsbrocken die da
in die tiefe rauschten
wir haben das gehört 7 leicht eine
schwerverletzte wie geht es den
überlebenden
die verletzten sind in zwei
krankenhäuser einmal ins
unfallkrankenhaus nach graz und
nachdruck an der mur gebracht wurden das
war gestern ein bisschen die
schwierigkeit auch schon die polizei das
zuzuordnen die zeugen zu finden und dann
auch zu vernehmen
wir haben gehört von andreas pichler
dass ein familienvater aus feldkirchen
bei graz der war auf einem vater sohn
ausflug mit gestern mit seinem kind mit
einem zehnjährigen und der hat hier auch
im lokalradio berichtet wie auf einmal
er einen knall gehört hat und dann ging
schon diese ganze gerölllawine über ihn
runter
sein sohn sei noch am hinterkopf
getroffen worden er konnte noch quasi in
letzter sekunde den rucksack froh über
ihn halten schützen vor über ihn halten
und sich danach dann auch um die
verletzten kümmern die er teilweise ins
eiskalte wasser gerissen worden waren
und er sagt also der schock kommt
letztlich erst später er muss das erst
verdauen
konntest du denn mit einheimischen
sprechen wie sie das ganze wahrgenommen
haben ja die bären schütz klamm ist seit
ca 120 jahren touristisch erschlossen
seit 176 ist ein naturpark ist ist
natürlich auch an heißen tagen heute
werden hier 32 grad in region erwartet
ist es ein willkommener ort der
abkühlung und natürlich ein ganz
gewaltiger touristischer faktor bis zu
700 touristen die in busladungen auch
gerade aus osteuropäischen ländern
hierher gebracht werden bevölkern an
manchen tagen hier die klamm und für die
regionen für die leute dort ist
natürlich jetzt auch ein problem wenn
erstens die wanderer aus bleiben und zum
zweiten die negativen nachrichten sich
in europa verbreiten
zumal einfach in der vergangenheit es
nie zu solch gravierenden ereignissen
gekommen ist es gab immer mal wieder
erst am vergangenen wochenende leichte
kieselstein große abgänge mehr oder
weniger gut einmal wanderer an den
fingern verletzt wurde aber nie so etwas
drastisches jetzt steht ja für viele
deutsche urlauber auch in der korona
zeit einen urlaub in deutschland
vielleicht auch in den bergen an
konntest du mit bergsteigern oder mit
profi sprechen wie man sich in solch
einem fall verhalten sollte wie man das
risiko verringern kann
dabei verletzt zu werden ja es war
gestern vor allen dingen für die
alpinpolizei für die bergretter eine
wahnsinnig anspruchsvolle aufgabe muss
dann mit vier hubschraubern letzlich
diese sehr unzugängliche klamm musste
eingesetzt werden um diese verletzten
überhaupt da zu retten
es war ja auch im wasser zum beispiel
noch ein treibender rucksack man gegen
bis zum abend davon aus dass vielleicht
noch weitere verschüttet oder vermisst
sein könnten
und letztlich schützen kann man sich
nicht wirklich davor wie gesagt heute
wird das gelände begangen ein geologe
soll sich das anschauen
aber ich habe mit bergrettern gesprochen
sie sagen auch wenn man netze spannen
würde überall stahlnetz diese
gesteinsbrocken diesen teilweise so
schwer die würden auch das durchschlagen
und auch wenn mein auto von einem stein
getroffen wird gebirgs gelände wird ja
nicht gleich die ganze straße gesperrt
also es geht niemand davon aus dass hier
diese beeren schutz klampfe immer dicht
gemacht wird als urlauber als wanderer
kann man sich glaube ich nur davor
schützen indem man überall im gebirge im
gelände die umgebung die natur im auge
behält und eventuell nach dieser
erfahrung so ein weg nur noch mit
schutzhelm mit fahrradhelmen macht um
einfach vor abgängen von steinen von
oben einigermaßen geschützt zu sein
jörg völkerling aus österreich danke für
deine einschätzungen